last night Christian told us he is
totally game to be a permanent part of
morning TV james franco is gonna be our
guest i'm really excited to interview
him and sit down with him how did you
discover this this fell gay um it's
later about to slay morning TV and look
us with us again alone for the second
time this week Christian took over the
slot vacated by Billy Bush this just 13
days after making a plea on Ellen to be
Michael Strahan's replacement on live
with Kelly yeah Kelly here r kelly ripa
existence winner I get a total kick out
if I had a great time Tom well there's
no official word yet on Kelly's new
co-host what would it take for some
morning TV fans dreams to come true
online polls I guess I don't know man so
look I'd love to do it it's certainly a
fun job golden globe-winning mr. robot
star is busy he's got a new movie out
called king cobra but Slater seems
pretty thirsty for another gig and maybe
some espresso to give him an early
morning edge whatever takes four shots
four shots in the morning that's how I
got